Hello everybody, welcome back to the wolf.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, we're on episode of...
Episode four.
Four, four, four, spooky, spooky, spooky.
Um.
Yeah.
Uh, I'm a little behind on my recording schedule, so I'm
just gonna jump right into it.
Um, it'll give us a recap of everything that happened
before, so.
This guy!
Wait a second.
Before I do that, I'm going to read this guy.
Bluebeard.
Ew.
Wait, after a long...
Bluebeard's mercy.
Bluebeard's last wife?
After a long...
Oh, here he is, here he is normal.
Bluebeard, wealthy scoundrel.
Bluebeard managed to escape the homelands with his riches
intact and continues to be one of the wealthiest fables in
New York.
Bluebeard sounds like a pirate name.
Is he based on a pirate?
The fable town government depends on his generous
contributions and he often uses his influence for his own
benefit.
As a former serial killer, he claims his days of
decapitating his brides are over.
He decapitated!
Wait, that is like the most incriminating thing about
everything here.
But even if he was able to leave his violet waste in the
homelands, that hasn't stopped him from making the
occasional trip down crooked lane.
Interesting.
What is this about his wife?
line of marriages resulting in mysterious disappearances.
Bluebeard's last wife in the homelands was naturally
suspicious of him.
One day he departed on business, leaving her alone in the
estate.
He gave her free reign of all the rooms, but made her
promise not to open the closet on the ground floor.
She defied him, as one does, of course, and discovered the
location of his missing wives.
All of them were just in the closet.
When Bluebeard returned, She revealed his murderous secret.
She persuaded him to allow her a moment to pray, which he
reluctantly granted.
This small mercy gave her brother's time to arrive and
rescue her.
And Bluebeard's crimes were exposed.
Oh.
Cool.
Wait, is that?
I'm going to look this guy up.
Learning about all sorts of...
Let's see, Bluebeard.
Fables from this game.
Bluebeard.
like donkey skin never heard of that one before oh it really
is blue beard is a classic French folk tale by Charles Perot
about a wealth wealthy monstrously blue bearded man who
murders his wives now don't folk tales and things of the
like have tend to have more like a moral to them sort of
like a oh yeah now what What could be...
What could be the lesson behind Bluebeard?
Don't murder your wives?
Don't murder people?
Hmm.
How funny.
Well, now we know.
Now we know a little bit more about him.
Because I was kind of like, who is this guy?
What's he doing here?
We missed two things.
In chapter 3 as well.
Probably because I did not go to uh...
What's his name?
This guy.
Crane, his apartment.
Interesting.
We don't even have anything about...
Oh, that's the doctor.
We don't even have anything like...
Oh, that's Bloody Mary.
I don't want to read that, just in case spoilers.
About his photos in his past times.
Okay.
Let's get into it then.
Yippee!
Episode four in sheep's clothing.
Oh.
If you can't afford to look human, you're going to the farm.
It's as simple as that.
Do you have any idea how much it costs to have an entire
family in glamour?
I can't finish the mirror.
It's missing a piece.
Crane must have taken a shard with him.
The open arms.
What if he threw it down the well?
That's what I was thinking.
explain before knowing down there big B how could you do
this to me this part was so funny I finally see you for who
you are everybody's grabbing each other's shoulders I don't
think he did it look at him do you really think this man
murdered these women do you really think this weeny murdered
these women you really think this weener guy yeah and then
we went like full psycho mode and we killed this guy.
Oopsie.
Go bad.
It was a good show.
But, you know.
You know.
Take him, okay?
Take Crane.
I like how we're like, take Crane, but he's just, he's, he's
walking on his own.
A beautiful relationship we have with you guys.
Really?
I mean it.
Out with the old, in with the new, long with the queen.
The audio balancing in this game is sometimes terrible
though oh my goodness i'm constantly constantly shifting up
shifting down on the on my volume do you think that piggy
guy is looking after us
oh it's like blood that's our blood yikes hello oh we're
hallucinating this see around yeah that's a that's a bad
dream bullets are a nasty business the silver slug deformed
and shredded on impact oh nasty he'll be okay though he'll
be okay his internal organs are positively riddled if i
don't extract every single scrap of silver he's liable to
suffer some long-term toxicosis toxicosis easy there try not
to move
Oh my god, that is the worst though.
Holy cow.
I figured I'd be done before you were conscious.
My arm!
I can do for the pain.
My arm.
Yes, very ugly.
But not life-threatening.
Are we sure?
The bone is literally sticking out.
Oh, don't...
Don't move it, please.
For real, though.
Look, I'm a bit engaged setting his life at the moment.
But if the fractured extremity...
he concerns him that much he can set it himself i'm sorry
hello heaven's sake oh no that wasn't as difficult was it
that'll do that'll do better off that'll do donkey oh he's
lucky to be alive and he won't be next time if he keeps
going like this he didn't listen to me before maybe he'll
listen i don't know about that well he should there are
limits to what even yeah i can hear you guys you know i
can't hear you quiet just relax relax is a big word oh my
gosh snow's outfit she's covered in my blood but perhaps
it'd be better if you gave me a few minutes to finish I
think I should stay at least until he's out of the woods.
Ah.
Believe me, Bigby couldn't be in better hands.
And I need the space to work.
So if you wouldn't mind, stick around.
Stick around, all right.
I don't know if I trust this guy.
Oh, please.
I could do this with my optic nerve.
It's not that I thought I just wanted to be here.
Just please.
I think she hates me now, though, because I killed a person.
Hey, Piggy friend.
Hey, Doc.
How much longer?
Colin, leave him be.
It's finished when it's finished.
Because I once watched a vet sew a turtle together in ten
minutes flat.
Colin, you're not even supposed to be here right now.
Oh, really?
Where am I supposed to be?
Colin shut up!
I'm here to take care of my friend.
Colin, shut the hell up, William.
Yes, that would be helpful.
Ooh, ew.
There.
All done.
Great.
Oh, it like shattered in him.
That's terrible.
This isn't a habit you should keep.
to having visits with me and well this time this time is no
joke eat as many metal shellings as you see fit but take
just one more silver round near your heart and the only
place I'll be visiting you is the morgue miss white he'll be
fine for light duty if he can figure out what that means he
knows what it means it's just been an unusual couple of days
yeah for sure but Don't give him the excuse.
His body will eventually give out.
Take care of him.
Please.
I will.
He'll need rest, I assume.
Sleep mostly.
She has enough on her plate.
Yeah, I think so.
Make sure he doesn't get into further altercations.
Snow has enough to deal with, Swineheart.
I can take care of myself.
Clearly.
Anyways, guard against, as they say.
Miss White, Sheriff?
Sheriff?
Colin.
Wait, do you think they're brothers?
I mean, his name is like, what was it, like swine something?
That is brother, and he's glamored.
What do the princesses do?
They don't need glamour, do they?
It's kind of nice.
How do you feel?
Hunky dory, baby.
It's Bigby, Snow.
He'll be okay.
Hell, I've seen him take worse.
Yeah, don't worry about me.
I'll be fine.
Oh, I'm being so cool.
this guy I'm being so cool calm and collected I'm glad
you're not dead that's what we said to you that's what we
said to you after you you stop breathing you know when you
passed out or or died I guess we died it it kind of scared
the hell out of me are we gonna kiss in front of Colin seen
you like that and when Swinehart arrived you know him he's
I'm here for you and even he thought you were you were
really worried you were really worried about me oh yeah you
were really fucked up Colin you look like Colin read the
room you're in bend its limbs the wrong way Colin read the
room Colin I'm just saying I was worried about him is all
the guy hasn't had a night's rest in days we'll all get some
rest when this whole thing is done what whole thing what's
even happening out there I mean do you guys have like a plan
or something and who should I be asking should I be worried
about the crooked man taking over yeah this is a bigger
thing still the thing we don't know bloody Mary the tweedles
this is bigger than what thought it was yeah the crooked man
came out of the shadows for a reason for him to attack us so
blatantly like that he either feels invincible or desperate
well if those are my two options I don't think I'd pick
desperate what do you mean you traded crane to save Bigby
I'm just saying that's not exactly something you do when
you're playing with house money so he called my bluff It's
not like I'm gonna let Bloody Mary just murder I'm not gonna
say we looked weak I'll thank her We gotta get in with snow
We gotta get in Thanks Snow For all that back there No
problem Oh Thanks You're not pissed that Crane's flown the
coop I mean what were we gonna do Yeah Snow had to do What
she had to Snow had to do what she had to What else could
Snow do?
Yeah exactly She didn't hand him over My ass would be down
the witching wall Uh-huh Crane still would have been taken.
Okay, okay, I'll take your word for it.
What do you want?
What do you even do?
You're just chilling up here in my apartment.
Just what does the crooked man want out of this?
I thought he was just a lone shark, but clearly he's
operating in other circles.
It can't just be about Crane, right?
Getting him out of town?
Is this all about the murders?
Crane can't be useful to him anymore.
So what could this have to do with Faith and Lily?
used sure though right crane was a puppet yeah yeah yeah the
crooked man worked the strings this is all about control of
fable yeah yeah yeah but then what do prostitutes have to do
with it lily and faith that i have no idea but i know it
does somehow what's their plan the crooked man declared war
against us last night at least that's what i thought when it
happened but now I see this war has been going on for years.
We just haven't noticed it because our way of doing things
is broken.
We need to do things the right way.
What is the right way?
Yeah.
Oh gosh, I'm agreeing with Colin.
I don't know, but it suspiciously sounds like your way.
My way.
Bigby's the one on the front lines.
You can't give him a leash.
He doesn't work that way.
What do you mean?
And thought behind things will never hurt anyone.
Yeah, I kind of...
Wait, what do you mean?
What is this right way?
We haven't been doing a good job.
You and I.
So, starting now, we do everything cut and dried by the
book, straight as an error.
I don't think that.
I think it's way past.
I think it's past the point of...
I'm not saying I'm the arbiter of...
Sure, you're not.
This town has enough monsters.
What happened last night, what you turned into...
It can't happen again.
We need monsters to fight monsters.
Colin, if I really believed that we needed him to lose his
flippin' mind at a moment's notice, then that would mean I'd
lost all faith in our ability to help this town.
Just let that side of you be done, okay?
I had no other choice, though.
And buried, and we can all move on.
Right?
We were under attack, Snow.
What did you expect me to do?
There are degrees.
Degrees?
Are we going to debate them when they're holding guns up to
us?
Really?
well if that's the case please explain to Colin what tearing
dumb's throat out was necessary it's what I do okay the
fight wasn't over oh you can't let up until the fight is
finished he was he was still a threat and that's all there
is to it sure look it's true though I care about how this is
done just as much as I care about it getting done so for
that you want to give him a handicap like the bad guys will
worry if shit gets sloppy everybody wants big B to smile and
shave and take a shower now and then hell I'm practically
the president who's asking for showers but this is the wrong
fucking time to put shackles on him oh I don't know he'll
get the job done just let him do it I'm going to I'm going
to let you do it okay it's just that now that i'm deputy
mayor i need your respect oh we are respecting it we've
always respected you situation right what situation all
unglamored fables starting today have to go and stay at the
oh give me a break this is feeling a little are you gonna
let her talk to me like that wait wait wait for a reason
colin and bigby knows it's for the best of the town it keeps
everybody yeah calm down everybody let's calm down everyone
just calm down yeah wait i'm perfectly calm I'm not.
Tell me right now.
What's it gonna be, Bigby?
Why do I have to do this aside?
I'm deciding the phone.
Hello?
Mushy Mushy.
Wolf's residence.
That's rude.
Buffkin, what is it?
Hey, don't be mean to...
Snow.
You're being a little mean.
I'll let him know.
Thanks.
Guess who's waiting in your office right now?
Narissa.
Narissa?
That broad from the pudding and pie?
Yes.
How does he know?
Apparently, she told Bufkin that she has something she needs
to talk to you about.
But that she'll only tell you.
And what do you think that could be?
Uh, Bigby's got an admirer.
You always do well with the, uh, disenfranchisement.
She probably knows something.
She knows something.
Yeah, yeah.
She's helped me a little with the case.
Maybe she has something else.
Maybe she does.
I should get back to the business office.
Are you, what, are you jealous?
I left Bufkin alone for too long taking calls.
What is Bufkin doing in the office?
out of these clothes.
Can that.
Great look.
Tabled, but not over.
Let me know when you're done with Narissa.
Aye, aye, Captain.
She's a piece of work.
I feel like she's going to go overboard with wanting the
respect, you know?
You're not really going to send me to the farm, are you?
Oh, wait, I don't like calling.
She seemed real serious about it, but I can still hang out
here.
Oh, Snow will change her mind.
She'll come around.
She's just...
The crane thing hit her hard, and she doesn't really know
who her friends are right now.
Oh, okay.
I get it.
Don't worry about it.
Colin will remember that.
I don't know.
I'm so not loyal to literally anybody.
I'm like, yes, no.
And then Colin, I'm like, as soon as somebody hits me in the
sympathy a little bit, I'm like, I cave.
Dang it.
I'm such an empath.
Arrgh.
Oh.
Hello.
I don't know like I understand where Snow White's coming
from obviously but also like she's I don't want her to like
feel a little like you know overcompensate trying to get
people to respect her and all right that wolf oh my gosh I
just wonder what they're what like the end goal is like you
take over Fable Town It almost feels like there would be
bigger plans.
You know what I mean?
Like, to take over normal humans as well.
But if that's the case, like, why would you kill fables?
You know what I mean?
Hmm.
Sheep's clothing.
Hi, Sheriff.
Hello.
Hi, Narissa.
Narissa.
Of the mermaid variety.
not anyone else obviously how
can we help you I um are you okay you didn't look good last
night I wasn't sure you'd be oh you should see the other
guys don't be fooled by this I didn't get the worst of it oh
I don't wait wait for coughing I don't know if we should oh
huff and puffs not many people smoke those what are those
what do you
smoke uh so what brings you here thanks please let me know
so what is it you wanted to talk to me about i know what you
did for me sending me the open arms i think you want to help
me again there's not a lot that i can talk about you know
that so that's spell crane wait what if you write it down
right it's not just while you're at work what i mean is i
don't want to waste your time but i don't want you wasting
your own time either okay yeah i mean back in the dressing
room at the pudding and pie i told you what i was looking
for and you found a way to tell me yeah yeah sent me to the
open arms yeah maybe that'll work
I just...
Just what?
Go ahead.
Uh...
It...
Might work.
Was Crane set up?
Crane wasn't the murderer.
The open arms was a setup.
You sent me there.
Was there someone else you wanted me to find there?
Beast?
These lips are sealed.
Uh...
If I could answer you just like that.
I wouldn't have had to make that appointment.
I feel like he's keeping secrets too.
Like he was at the bar and Beauty was just like...
Yeah, why were you there?
We never even got an answer on that.
He might be acting all like, I care about beauty.
I care about my wife, but...
I used to have friends to help me find my way.
Oh, Sebastian.
Oh, he's boiled.
He's crawfish soup.
You could trust me.
Is this making any sense?
No.
saying you need a friend right now you can trust me what I'm
saying is friends matter and I I don't have any left she
hates that blonde girl I hope you're looking after yours oh
are you are my friends in danger look around you who are you
talking about are my friends in danger I'm sorry am i stupid
what i need you to know i want to help but but your lips are
sealed but your lips are
sealed i'm sorry if i'm wasting your time i thought i knew
how to say it ribbons
like it do you like it hmm do you what it's not about how it
looks i don't know it looks that concerns me it's what it
does that's why you can't tell me anything it's the ribbon
isn't it oh could we take it off just cut it i don't know
yoink just what are we doing
move it will she die can we take it off let's ask take the
ribbon off no it flips your field what you can't just stay
back you can't do that slow down it's all right i'm not
gonna do anything is that their heads come off i wonder
please don't is that why they're all getting decapitated
okay i guess it so the ribbons if you take them off uh i i'm
sorry sorry why should i wish i could do something norissa
will remember that if anyone finds out i came here just i
don't know probably snow uh listen sheriff Can you keep this
conversation between us?
I could be in a lot of trouble.
I shouldn't be talking to you.
I have to tell...
She knows that I was here, though...
Or that you were here, though.
She has to know about the ribbons.
If you have to, just...
Don't tell anyone else.
Oh, ye.
Oh, I'm not...
I'm not...
Sorry.
I just need to talk to the sheriff for a moment.
Please excuse us.
We're just having...
I might have a new lead for you, but I don't know how solid
it is.
Oh, I like the new suit.
They said they wanted to talk to you about something.
I wonder if they've heard about Crane.
Thank you for listening, Sheriff.
I think it's Beast.
You should go onto your next business.
I don't think you'll be wasting your time.
Wait, you don't have to go.
Oh.
That was...
abrupt it's one way to send a message what did she tell you
i didn't mean to rush her out yeah magic keeps her from
talking she couldn't really say anything yeah the magic that
crane was talking about it's in the ribbon and you can't
take the ribbon off or it's how faith and lily died yeah
okay then good work thank you haven't any bad intentions in
here i'm not doing a little place to look oh we weren't
tangoing the crooked man or do you think they just heard
about last night and they're scared about what's nurse
appointed us that's what narissa was doing telling us to go
there i think she made it as clear as she could have let's
go hmm what you know beauty came to me a while back
Financial assistance.
I told her there was nothing I could do, and...
And she said that meant she'd have to go somewhere else.
Pigby, you don't think she meant that she was going to go to
the Crooked Man, do you?
That would explain why they called.
We need to solve this before something else happens.
Who knows what?
I have other matters to- Wait, what?
What do you mean?
Oh, uh, oh, oh, that's abrupt.
I thought we were gonna go talk to them together.
Beauty and Beast's apartment.
I'm eavesdropping.
The walls are so thin here.
That doesn't mean I have to agree to it.
And when were you going to tell me, or were you just going
to keep that a secret too?
I didn't think that when she said she would resort to other
things, I thought it was meant the job at the at the uh
hotel i'm eavesdropping go off in a puff i'm knocking hello
oh she mushy this says knock but it's really like aggressive
pounding oh it's you what are you doing here you called no
yeah what's this about you called right or uh uh was it
beast i didn't call you listen i've had a shitty night well
you're not the only one and i really don't want to deal with
the run around snow said you called and wanted to talk to me
if someone called it must have been beast i certainly didn't
okay okay i you know if you had just kept your mouth shut
about me the beast wouldn't have lost his head over at the
open arms i never would have even found the place and i
wouldn't have had just Spend the night defending myself for
keeping secrets with the Bigby Wolf.
Errm.
I lost my job because of you.
I needed that.
Who's there?
Beauty?
Can I talk to the beast?
You don't want to talk.
Can you just get beast for me?
I don't know.
Talking has a way of escalating with you.
What the...
You're... Okay, he started it, though.
For real.
Bigby's here.
Can you give us a minute?
A word in private?
I think that's a good idea.
Their place is so fancy.
Err.
I'll just make myself at home then.
I'm still caring around him.
I guess I really do have the smallest apartment in the
woodlands.
We still have this huge watt of cash in our...
I don't know what the electric bill is for that thing.
In our pocket.
La la la.
Oh, what's in there?
Oh, it's an urn.
Oh, Mrs. Potts.
Oh, why would you do that?
Why would you do that?
Painting.
Hmm.
Talk about living in the past.
Out of money and up against the wall here.
Out of money and up against the wall.
Can we finish this later?
Now that Bigby's here, let's just...
Hidden room?
No?
We're just knocking on everything.
Oh, hello!
sorry we've had a long night yeah what's that you always say
centuries of marriage come with centuries of baggage i gotta
say your place it looks uh expensive expensive what's that
supposed to mean beauty what it's a fair question he's the
sheriff oh yeah aren't you in debt i thought you were having
money problems but it doesn't look like you're suffering to
me is this something you took out crooked man oh that's part
of it but we can't bring him into this he's just going to
make things worse he always does well he's here now so let's
see what he can do why are you being like this i'm just
trying to do what's best this is so awkward don't waste my
time come on i'm not here to referee you called me okay so
cut the bullshit and quit wasting my time just answer what
if we did have some information on the crooked man yeah if
we talk we're putting ourselves at risk could you protect us
I've seen what happens when you cross him can you can you
promise you'll keep us safe if we talk okay I can protect
you but only if you tell me what I need to know and that
means details no more stonewalling yeah we're not they will
remember that and just tell me what's going on here yeah you
get used to a certain way of doing things and sometimes it
just gets away from you i just wanted to give beauty the
kind of life she deserves you understand that don't you and
so they put themselves a lot of work out there into debt
because of the fancy apartment like i
just wanted someone gonna get there who's gonna get there i
can't be hi there you've
to keep up with the joneses oh my god i can't stand them
possible oh my god i'm gonna come down there and brush your
heads in with that mishark
thinking about how else you can settle this who is that oh
oh who is that say something if i have to hear that message
i find the crooked man who do i talk to where do i go oh my
god these that please just speak lucky pawn that's where i
borrowed the money lucky pawn the crooked man's behind that
place okay i'd overheard people talking to jersey about
loans before so when i needed money yeah who's jersey where
i went wait who do you deal with jersey you know the jersey
devil the jersey Where is he, devil?
There are cryptids in this game!
The most tweedles were always going in and out.
Probably dropping off a loan payment they squeezed out of
some poor fable.
But never the crooked man.
Mainly it's just regular fables.
I can see now that it was a mistake.
But I'm not the only one who goes there, you know.
I saw the woodsman's axe there just the other day.
It was in a display case.
too.
There's a lot of that going around.
I can't imagine he has a lot of marketable skills.
Yeah, Mary must have got the axe from there then.
Bloody Mary must go through there.
She had Woody's axe last night.
Trying to chop my damn head off with it.
Maybe if you go there, you can sort some things out.
I guess I'll go check out the lucky pawn.
If I can't track down the crooked man there.
I think a rumple still skin's going to be there.
I think I feel like that guy's got to be in this game.
Hold on, Vicky.
Don't go there.
like you're just going to get beauty in trouble and i have
to go you know that butcher shop the cut above oh the
butcher yeah yeah it's the place on tubman street same block
as the baker and the candlestick maker well i've been
delivering packages from there for a while the thing is it's
for the crooked man and i don't think it's meat in the
packages you got I need it work.
Oh, he doesn't know.
Did you deliver to the crooked man?
Yeah.
Did you ever deliver to the crooked man?
Can you give me an extra help?
Yeah, if he says he doesn't know what it was in there.
I delivered to places all over town, but never to the man
himself.
It never seems to be heading to the same place.
Because Tweedledee and Tweedledum had the butcher, the
butcher package too.
How did you get involved with this?
Yeah, for real.
Johan the butcher called.
He had a problem with the refrigeration unit one night.
it was your pal mary who showed up to pay me she said i was
reliable and she liked that oh it's the only thing i've been
able to pick up and it's still not enough i don't want
beauty to have to work especially not where she was is mary
always there yeah bloody mary is there no music is so loud
hands over the packages you know day to day but i've seen
her around there she uh gets under my skin you know i i try
to avoid her but i don't need to tell you what she said
you're damn right you don't i don't need a rundown on her
reputation if mary works out of there i need to look into it
yeah so i guess we're gonna have to decide if we want to go
to the butcher provide for beauty give her the kind of life
she deserves these guys are insufferable we shouldn't have
to live like this scraping to get by none of us should we
were royalty once we were accustomed to a certain lifestyle
All we want is to make this place feel a little bit like
home.
You wouldn't understand, Bigby.
Oh.
Fuck off.
There are a lot of fables who have it a lot worse off
than...
For real.
For me, for that matter.
So, where are you going?
Oh, we were royalty.
If this all goes sideways, I'd like to know...
Now I have to work?
I have to lift a finger?
It's funny because...
beast is like so you know he's he's beast and he's so
useless
i feel like the butcher shop i want to know what's in those
packages let's go to the butcher shop you know that butcher
shop the cut above yeah let's go to the butcher i want to
know what the crooked man is hiding yeah me too you know
bigby once you show up there word is going to spread There
may be nothing left for you to see if you go to the lucky
pond after.
Ah.
Well, I guess I'll find out.
I didn't think about that, but...
Oh, too late to...
Wait, I don't know what you're planning to do when you find
the crooked man, but is there any way you could help us out?
Music is awesome.
Well, maybe you can make this all just... go away.
We would really appreciate it.
What do you say?
can you help us you want me to kill him aren't you is that
what you think i do no of course not i don't know how you'd
get that idea we just we know that the crooked man is
dangerous to all of fable town i'm gonna do my job hey yeah
you that might just solve your problems anyway oh thank you
They are so...
Oh my god!
Oh, things just get worse when he's involved.
And then...
And then, oh, Big B, please, Big B, please, will you help
us, Big B?
Will you make our problems go away, Big B?
I'm gonna keep smoking.
I'm a Big B who don't care no more.
We don't care no more.
Let's see, what we got?
cold drinks what do we have in here some tater chips cola
and a lemon lime and a lemon lime slim pickens what do we
got pork chop no more filet mignon please ring the bell oh
they love new york the cut above
But what frozen meat?
It looks like an ice cream.
Like where you get...
Not very appetizing.
Frozen solid.
Who'd want to eat this?
Yeah.
It's a front, Big B!
It's a front!
Huh.
Empty.
Either he's got a whole lot of customers, or he doesn't have
any.
Is that a banana drink?
Oh!
Mushy move.
Yoshi.
Big B Wolf?
Yeah.
Well, welcome, Sheriff.
What can I get for you?
You interested in a particular cut?
Who is this guy?
Let's see.
What do we have in stock?
Let's see what we got here.
I like how we just leave a trail everywhere.
Flying steak on special.
New York strip.
Because of our cigarettes.
Oh, I can have some.
wild boar in tomorrow if you like uh sirloin ribs roast
tongue got some tongue where's bloody mary hangs around here
i want to talk to her i i don't know what you mean this
guy's sweating up a storm what you see is what you get just
meet you'll find anything else
Wholesale and meat-packing and walk-up service.
I'd like to help you really I really mind if I said nothing
Mind if I look around you don't mind if I take a look
around.
Yeah, I guess not.
Okay, great.
Thank you.
I Sheriff I Yeah, are your hands clammy.
Did you hear that?
What?
What oh, I'm real sorry.
Hold on.
I just got to go check on that.
Oh, don't go anywhere.
I'll be right back.
Oh, no I just have to go see Well, let's, uh, we're going
in.
Uh, we're opening this up.
Ruh-roh.
Shit.
Ooh, nasty!
Oh, this is scary.
Ooh.
I got it covered back here, Sheriff.
I'll be right out.
I'm ready for QTEs.
I'm ready.
They won't get me this time.
Let's just...
Let's just talk!
Relax, Johan.
I just want to talk.
With my fists.
I'm sorry, Sheriff, but you're not supposed to be back here
for safety purposes.
Uh-huh.
There's a lot of...
Pigies.
Oh!
You think they're from the farm?
There.
I'm just gonna...
Just make my way downtown.
Through the pigs.
Piggy, piggin, piggin' away.
Piggy, piggy, pig.
Oh, you gotta be kidding me.
What's that?
They're gonna kill me.
Oh, God, she is gonna fucking kill me.
He's gonna get me killed.
How you doing?
Yeah.
Please, please don't.
Big me.
What happened to Shera?
Please, don't kill me, Shera.
Oh, God.
Please, please don't kill me.
Talk or else.
Don't kill me.
Tell me everything you know.
I might have to do just that.
Is that what you want, Johan?
No, no, please.
You don't have to do that.
I'm dead.
Either way, they said to me, Johan, you can keep your life
and lose your shop or lose both.
What would you do?
It was a simple choice to make.
Who's that, yeah.
They?
Do you mean Mary?
Bloody Mary?
This isn't my shop anymore.
That crew took it from me a long time ago.
Speak, Johan.
It was.
Oh.
D and dumb.
And that mental case, Bloody Mary.
You want to talk about the real butcher?
It's her.
Not me.
This is her place.
I'm telling you.
They muscled in on.
Let him talk.
delivery a long time ago all cause of that heat wave that
summer was even hotter than this one I'd let Mary and those
porkers stay cool in the meat locker one day playing cards
having a great time I guess they were sizing the place up oh
shows what I get for being nice I'm just a victim in this I
don't know what they do back there I swear victim and I
don't want I will say we're about to see what's back there
and then we'll see if I believe you don't turn your back
this would happen.
Didn't know when, but there would be the day.
I'm listening first.
Open it up.
Black magics.
Witches!
Tongue of dog!
Run?
Oh, that's what the light was for.
It wasn't light.
It was to, oh.
Nosebleed, swine snout.
What were they experimenting on?
What is this place?
I told you, Big P. I don't know.
They muscled me out.
But you told, you let them know.
No, you informed them to leave.
I haven't been back here when it was like this.
I don't believe him at all.
He knew that, yeah.
You press that button.
This business.
It's all I've ever had.
You help them escape!
You can't act like you're forced into this and then turn
around and help them.
They'd still be here if you hadn't flipped that switch up.
Yeah!
I had to.
Huh.
What?
You come in here making trouble for me.
But you only give a shit now because the crooked man stepped
on your toes or something.
Where were you when they took this place from me?
We didn't even know!
It hasn't been easy for me.
You think I want to live with this at my back?
You're not in the clear yet.
You're not off the fucking hook yet, Butcher.
Yeah.
If I find something, I so much as smell something that makes
me think you're lying.
I like the red light as it has, like, run written underneath
it.
Just to remind everybody, if that's on, you gotta get out of
here.
So this is what Beast was delivering.
Glamours.
Glamours, yeah.
Other kinds of magic.
Could be dangerous stuff.
Oh, okay.
Chemistry lab.
Oh, wow.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, this is magical breaking bird.
Yippee!
That symbol.
It's on all the packages.
Yeah.
That's the crooked man's brand.
It's on everything that goes in and out of here.
So you do know something, huh?
Mm-hmm.
Is that a wheel or what?
It's a compass, no?
I guess they never used that thing on wolves, huh?
What's that supposed to do?
a mean it's from back in the homelands a torture oh came
over here with the rest of our stories not that mondays need
any help coming up with that kind of thing it makes people
crooked by breaking their bones and do i really need to
explain this okay what is all this is their supplies no or
stock yeah looks like math or something Yeah.
It looks like math.
Oh man, numbers are just...
Where we got, yeah, what's there behind here?
Oh!
Shit.
Is everybody on here?
Do you know anything about this?
I don't know.
A lot of fables out there need a lot of things.
Maybe just don't touch anything back here.
Please?
To the farm, when available.
it's funny because it's just like how many fables are there
really like i mean clearly they're getting a little like
liberal with it because they're including the jersey devil
and and such but at the same time it's like kind of funny
what's this mysterious jars materials for making magic
anti-green leaf and any other rogue witches out there
probably get their supplies here Yeah, and everything is,
yeah, like, black forest soil.
And it shows, like, what each person is getting.
Sorry, I was trying to look at that.
Like, A, 110, A.
And whatever this, wait.
The shackles, please.
What?
Chains.
Who's getting chained up here?
You can't think I'm the only one the crooked man has under
his yoke.
who is being who is being wronged by the crooked man stood
up then they would be able to defeat the crooked man don't
you see what's going on here all these fables get magic from
him business is booming he's got all he needs the raw
materials and the slave labor to process him and with all
this gear looks like they could make just about any kind of
magic.
A lot of it.
That's pretty clear why.
Oh, yeah?
Why?
Doing it like this, it's bound to be cheaper than the 13th
floor.
This is just horrible.
The things that must have gone on here.
Crooked Man's gonna pay.
When I get my hands on that crooked bastard, I'm gonna make
him pay for all this.
People just don't know the real cost something cheap you
don't have to tell me that fucker crane knew all about it oh
yeah what about crane yeah crane he sucks i mean finding the
crooked man is so fucking important why don't you ask your
boss because i don't have him anymore no crane he said he
knows where everybody is what i don't know how but he's got
some way that's right it was that creepy yeah with the big
green head and all creepy magic just use that find the
crooked man that way and leave me alone yeah with stuff like
that yeah that's that's not your concern we don't need to
tell them we don't need to leave none of your business
butcher don't worry about yeah we hit we don't need to be
let another brandos you know important magical item there's
only one place they've taken where's that the lucky pawn oh
it is the lucky pawn The lucky pawn.
If I can find the mirror piece there, wait, don't say that
out loud.
Well, I'm real happy you found what you're looking for,
Bigby.
But what about me?
Huh?
What the hell am I supposed to do now?
I'm going to have to spend the rest of my shoulder.
You're on your own.
I'll take care of him.
You won't have to worry, Johan.
I'm going to take him down.
down.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sheriff.
Hmm.
Is he so innocent, though?
Are any of these people so innocent?
Oh.
How did they escape from in there?
I wonder.
Maybe there's, like, a trap door up top or something.
Clear.
Completed chapter three of episode four.
Jersey, don't give me that shit.
What the fuck is point of having a system if you're just
gonna Jack what the fuck is going on oh I'm uh just gonna
you know oh his his axe he wants his axe why'd you pawn it
in the first fucking place oh no oh yeah push him I don't
know I didn't pawn it asshole it was stolen from my
apartment oh so get the fuck out of my sight hit the bricks
see you later holy cow what's going on here what the fucking
hell and this fucking guy too are you kidding me it was here
it was right fucking here what did you do with it how the
fuck do I know it's your store you're gonna move you piece
of shit oh taking Jersey away yeah get away yeah you're
dealing with me yeah you got here fast still looking for
whoever killed them hookers or are you done chasing your
tail where's my axe who'd you give it to jersey watch
yourself watch yourself you do not want to go there and what
if i do see the guy that's banned from the bar you talk but
i don't think you got the stones to back it up oh oh so are
we why should mary get all the you ain't so tough this guy
This ain't gonna go like...
I'm not even gonna let you finish talking.
Right into the nails.
Yeah.
What the hell are you doing?
This is my fucking fight.
Not now, dog.
You got a lot of nerve.
Can we... Why can't we be friends?
Why can't...
Woo!
So cool!
Hey!
Stop it!
Oh, what's in there?
Oh, his axe!
Why is his glamour so ugly?
Oi!
There she is!
One more?
Oh, it didn't work.
One more.
Oh, Kio, kio, kio, kio, kio, kio, kio.
Not the antler.
Ouch, out, out, out, out, out.
Oh, my gosh.
How did... Oh, oh, oh, oh, how could you let him do that to
you?
Uh,
this thing.
The Headless Horseman!
It's...
And stay down.
Holy cow.
Oh, holy cow!
Everyone's just axing each other all the time.
I must...
ask you a question.
Oh, now we can talk...
Yo, now we can...
The magic mirror's missing shard.
Where is it?
Bloody Mary brought it here, didn't she?
You don't know anything about anything do you what do you
have nothing had useless bitch snow white in a broken
fucking mirror no fucking friends no clue i got you what
does that mean i want to nothing i still have you don't i
you can't find a crooked man no one can he's so cool the
door to his house It bounces around.
Oh, interesting.
Never in one spot.
You'll never find it.
That's new information.
Even Crane had to use the magic mirror.
They dumped all his shit here.
Bloody Mary uses this place like a fucking dump.
Why are you telling me all this?
Fucking bitch.
Why just tell me this?
Are you trying to rush me out of here?
I'm trying to make a point, dog.
Dog.
You can have all the information you fucking want.
It's not going to help you when the time comes.
And at time, it's a coming.
It's a coming.
Just go on.
Get Crane's shit and go.
Not that it's going to do you any good.
This guy.
See anything?
Crane's coat.
It's got to be in the pocket, though.
Pocket one?
No time for travelers, Jackson.
Take the money.
He won't be needing this.
I'm always just...
How much money have I stolen from this guy now?
I like how he was smirking, too.
That sick piece of...
Smirking when he took the money, too.
How much money do I...
We got it!
It's the shard.
Finally.
It looks much smaller than it did on the...
You know?
Hey, Shad.
Yeah.
Those girls are still dead.
Oh, and there's nothing you could do to bring them back.
And I don't know what they did.
But I do know this.
Oh, if they're dead, it's because the crooked man wanted
them dead.
That's all it takes.
I don't feel like we need to...
Let's hear him out.
Shit.
You can wail on me all day.
you want but what he might say something do you because he
ain't in your town you're and he is and he sure his is ready
for you
he's just trying to psych us out only if you like huff and
puffs
uh give him one give him one he helped us out he helped us
out with the axe
I'm not that... I'm not that bad of a gay.
Thanks.
Shitty grand.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, that's all I've ever heard.
I'm not gonna lie.
I was having trouble deciding which one of you to hit with
this thing.
Hey.
Jersey was wrong, you know.
About why?
those girls.
There is something you can do about it.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Is that the plan?
I'll do my job.
You get him.
Yeah.
That's my job.
Yeah, I'm doing my job!
I'm doing my job!
I get paid, I think.
I guess so.
I'll see you around.
Hey, Woody.
Yeah.
I'll see you around, all right?
Yeah, I'll see you.
Is this the last time we're going to see him?
Come on, stop to the Bahamas.
I've never been to the Bahamas.
I've always wanted to go to the Bahamas.
I don't care who killed the prostitutes.
If Crane was helping himself to the community coffers, it
means his hand was in my pocket.
And you just let him go.
I don't know what you heard, But it didn't happen like that.
Are you denying the fact?
Oh, she's denying me the chance to get a word.
Mr. Toad!
I can't remember if Binghamutty has returned.
Hey, everybody's so mean to me.
You will have to wait.
Just one moment, please.
Look what I found.
Da-da-da-da!
Seems your dog wants a biscuit.
Hey!
Buffkin, get this piece in the mirror right away.
With pleasure, Miss White.
Finally, things are swinging back in the right direction.
Maybe.
Good work, goodby.
You've been gone all day.
What did you uncover?
I thought you were going to report back to me.
I mean, it's fine.
Crane used the mirror to find him.
Once the mirror's fixed, we can use it to find that crooked
bastard.
Yeah.
Or at least wherever he hangs his hat.
That's how Crane kept tabs on him.
And everybody else.
abusing the privilege he was probably spying on all yeah he
was probably spying on me anyway no he was spying on all of
us you did excellent by the way all of us i could use your
assistance would you join me at the mirror well why do you
need my help sure don't go far sheriff i'm right here a few
words of my own take a number take a number i don't
understand This piece just doesn't want to join the rest.
Do you have any idea why?
That's what I was, I was like, it doesn't look like the
piece that is there.
Well, where did you find it?
What has it gone through since being separated from the
rest?
Shattering is a very traumatic experience, you know.
So this process can be a little touchy.
The crane had it on.
The crane was carrying it for a part of the night at least.
Found it in his coat.
Yeah.
It's pretty amazing.
It's still intact after the fight, the kidnapping, and then
riding around with bloody marriage.
Ah, yes, Miss White was asking about her.
Uh-huh.
That explains it.
You know who and the mirror have a very unhappy history with
each other.
A bloody mirror because they're mirrors?
Uh, yeah, yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Well, I think I know how to proceed now.
You gotta sweet talk it a little bit.
Yeah.
You gotta baby it a little bit.
Oh, I was sad.
Science Witch, he might not want to come out with you
watching.
Why?
Oh, he doesn't like being spied on.
huh is it fixed did you ask about the crooked man fucking
still working on it he said it might be a while i can't
believe we found the piece and it's still gonna be a while
what do you want from the business office i'll buy i can't
take those two right now we're trying to catch a murderer
and they're they're just bickering they're over there
bickering about bureaucracy At war, don't they realize that?
Oh, his mouth is not open.
Yeah, thanks.
Go talk to Toad.
But just so you know, we can't pay him.
Wait, why?
He really needs to go to the farm, you know.
Oh, no!
We're sending him to the farm.
Oh, Mr. Toad.
Toad.
Come here.
I see how it is.
Passed off to an underling, eh?
Why?
Well, you did cause what damage brings me in here, so maybe
it's for the best.
Just need a little bit of dosh to cover it.
I tried talking to her about it, but it's like chatting up a
brick wall, it is.
Now, I'm sure you've got your own agenda, Sheriff.
But I've taken a real wallet.
Do you know the crooked man?
Before we get into any of that, let's ask him.
What do you know about the crooked man?
He might know something.
Don't try to change a subject on me.
I need a little bit of that.
around money you know i don't think he knows anything but
the gaping mall in my wall any of us sound familiar i'm not
looking for a hand give crane's money wait why would i say
it's not my fault crane won't be getting any use out of this
i've been stealing from him this entire time just to give
him mr toad i suppose that means it belongs to me as much as
anybody thank you you're welcome is it to get glamored toad
yeah got the money now so i won't be so lenient if i
actually he needs to also fix his stuff so always on the
table but of course good I love mr.
dog I think I'm obsessed with him low beard you want to talk
I've just made my donation funding this office so direct
your questions to miss white well at least he's not trying
to get rid of me sure for now for now did you take care of
toad i mean i saw the way he left i know it may not seem
that important right now he's out of ours are the law for a
very good reason he's out of our hair for now i'll take care
of it later i told him we'd work it out soon he'd get out of
our hair we don't have time to worry about that right now
big b what did i tell you he's unglamored when this whole
thing is over i'll send him to the farm no questions asked
okay oh but tj fine we'll deal with it later.
What did you do?
I know I should be asking how it got like this, but I just
keep wondering why it happened to Faith and Lily.
Right.
You've seen his world.
Do you have any idea why he'd want them dead?
I don't know if the crooked man killed them with his own
hand.
I honestly don't know.
It was one of his goons, but someone did.
It's about control, maybe?
If there's one thing I figured out, it's that the crooked
man is all about control.
It's what he does with the paddles chains and ribbons maybe
faith and lily weren't doing what they were told or maybe
they just tried to leave sheriff miss white i believe the
mirror is repair yuppie i have to say i have been better but
thanks for putting me back together i'm sorry i just i have
to know what mirror mirror we're glad you weren't slang now
please show us that sick creep Yeah.
Uh, I'll just let it happen.
He's probably still waking up a little.
Uh-huh.
Oh, she looked like a lizard.
You know when lizards, like, bob their heads up.
You will get on that plane to Paris, and you will wait for
the day the crooked man needs you.
Until then, not a peep.
Otherwise, I get to deal with you my way.
So please, please, disobey.
Someone's watching.
How does she know?
Ew!
Because she comes from the mirror.
She's Bloody Mary.
We pointed the wrong direction and looked at Bloody Mary's
reflection.
Oh, her.
That explains the sting.
I'd rather not have to feel the pain she brings.
Ugh!
So, let's not do that again, okay?
Okay.
like we'll have to track him down later he's going to paris
we need to focus on the immediate threat imagine they sent
him to brazil bigby we don't have a lot of time okay mirror
mirror mirror no time to pout so where does crooked man hang
out oh i don't recognize the door yeah but that's a signal
that's the crooked man symbol on it yeah hold on
it changes whoa it moves yeah jersey mentioned that wait a
minute i know that door where's that central park central
park i don't know when it's gonna move again but i'm gonna
get there before it does big b wait when you get the crooked
man make sure you bring him back alive he has to stand trial
oh this can't be like it was with tweedle dumb i don't care
if it gets out of hand you don't let it come to that i know
that emotions can run high and you have your reasons to
handle this a certain way but we have to make a commitment
to working with but oh I'll catch him and bring him back
here oh we can clean him and cook them together oh I have
enough to worry about here but so I'm going to trust you to
handle this properly that is if you think you're ready I'm
the judge jury and executioner baby I should have said no
guarantees because I don't know how I'm going to feel in the
moment.
What about...
Wait, is that the bridge that's in Enchanted?
That would be so funny.
Oh, there it is.
I'm going in.
Whoa.
No, it's going to disappear if I...
I'm running!
Whoa!
This is...
freaky stealth
mission oh not so stealthy Tim what the hell are you doing
here good evening sheriff I'm here to take you to the boss
oh thanks by the way for leaving off tiny tiny to him you
think I'd have outgrown that centuries ago uh I have to
admit when they asked me to watch the door I wasn't sure
what to expect when you came through that portal but I get
it you're not here on a social wait so you were expecting
yeah just been waiting for me to show up eventually that's
what they told me I don't know they said you made it pretty
clear I'm supposed to believe a little Kimmy is involved in
this if you'll come this way look this is the one thing I
have to do okay get this over with let's get this over with
Yeah, come on.
Come on.
That's all I want, Sheriff.
What?
Why are you involved?
Oh my gosh.
The symbol again.
What is going on?
Thanks for understanding.
This is all I'm here to do, and I don't want to mess it up.
I know I'm probably the last person you'd expect to be a
guard or an escort for the matter.
Yeah, you're a part of this, man.
What are you doing?
Tim, how can you be working here?
You know who this guy is, don't you?
He's not...
What?
It's not as bad as you think.
Oh my god.
He doesn't treat me like some broken little kid.
I think he gets what it's like.
Ah.
He gave me a job.
And I'm lucky to have it.
This is the only option I've got.
Just...
Find another job.
Because if you and the boss go up against each other, the
rest of Fable Town is going to get caught in the mail.
Working means you're involved, though.
You realize you're not just minding the door.
Work for that crooked bastard.
Your hands get dirty, too.
it's not so bad not so bad yeah he's a murderer so you're
telling me you agree with everything crane does no that's
why we got rid of him a lot of us depend on him some of us
never get to the front of line at the business office but
he's there we need you but we need him too what we don't
need is a war hey sheriff hold up i gotta go in with you
okay let's wait for it i don't Let's not be like that.
Yeah.
You first.
Go ahead.
You got a job to do.
We're following the process.
Oh, that's everybody.
Hello?
Oh, even her!
Sorry about your brother.
I'm not so sorry.
Just a little sorry.
Thank you, Tim.
I know the sheriff isn't the accommodating sort, but you
handled it.
You did well.
You can go now.
Thank you, sir.
You see, everyone in Fable Town has a role to fill.
You just have to pay attention to what they need to help
them find it.
Oh.
Even her.
Is that why Narissa said she had no friends?
All right.
I've got a smoke.
This is the crooked man.
Cinema.
Ah!
Episode four!
Bloody Mary.
In the old days, how you picked up those men one time.
Why are we running in slow motion?
Oh, okay, never mind.
The wolf is coming.
And they would wait.
Hiding anywhere they could squeeze their pathetic, shivering
corpses.
Some would just drop to their knees where they stood, close
their eyes, and wait for death.
And you'd give it to them.
What are you trying to say, huh?
I wish I could have seen it.
Oh, well.
Oh,
okay, sorry.
I thought we were against it, or we went the other way.
Did you send Colin to the farm?
You and 85% of players decided Colin should not go to the
farm.
Did you attempt to remove Narissa's ribbon?
You and 63% of players did not try to remove the ribbon.
I wonder if we would have killed her right then and there if
we had done it.
Or she would have freaked out if we, like, tried to.
Which crooked operation did you investigate first?
63% of players went to the cut above.
first i feel like i've been playing the game pretty like how
most people are playing the game you know what i mean like
probably for their first time you and 73 of players that
decided toad should not go to the farm we just we've just
been a nice guy you and 43 of players lit a cigarette that's
like the that's like the most the the coolest the coolest
response well we just have One, one episode left.
We finally meet the crooked man.
He's not as crooked as I expected him to look.
I thought his arms were going to be like...
You know what I mean?
I thought he was going to look like a cactar.
Or something.
Oh, scary.
It's so loud.
But...
I want to know what his MO is for real.
I'm a little Timmy being like, no, he's not so bad.
He gave me a job.
Yeah, like the guy is so...
The guy is working with like Bloody Mary and scary people
and is all about the control and stuff.
And I don't know.
We'll see how we can...
Hopefully we can bring some peace to Fable Town and everyone
can live a decent lives.
Um, I like Mr. Toad, but I just want Mr. Toad to be okay.
We'll work in the favor of Mr. Toad, I believe.
I don't work for the people.
I don't work for Fable Town.
I work for Mr. Toad in his best interests.
How we could sooner get him to hell.
I'm surprised Mr. Toad's not a part of this operation.
Nah, my guy just wants to drive crazy through the streets of
London and go to hell.
Well, that was that one last chapter, one last chapter,
yeah, episode.
I keep getting the chapter and episode terminology mixed up,
but that's okay.
I hope you guys have been enjoying the wolf among us, and we
will finish it next time!
Yippee!
The first episode was like so long.
I expected every episode to be like two-ish hours.
So, I'm surprised that the...
Maybe the next one will be like the longest.
Probably?
Maybe.
Thank you so much everybody!
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time, show,
and I will see you when I haunt you next!
Boo!
Bye bye!
Thank you!
you